Namir putin and i will discuss all the
steps to be taken in order to maintain
the territorial integrity of Syria and
to cleanse the northern parts of Syria
from terrorists and terrorist
organizations
we will also be revisiting the efforts
made for drafting a new constitution and
we will also discuss ed Lib and the
significance attached to this area
including a ceasefire we want a lasting
peace in Syria
I hope our meeting will make progress
meanwhile Syria's President Bashar
al-assad has called president Erewhon a
thief he made the remarks during a visit
areas of Idlib province taken from
Turkish backed rebels by government
forces - oh do Gambia in the hollow
haired ones a thief he stole our plants
and factories are we produce and he
stole our oil with the help of ISIL now
he is stealing our lands and who we are
called hallelujah they'd want alleges to
have entered Syria of his own choice
however over the past nine years he has
been trying but couldn't or rather not
authorized he said to have informed the
Americans has he you are simply a
servant you were ordered to enter and
you did allow correspondent Charles
Stratford is in jail on piano that's
near the turkish-syrian border Charles
with the clock ticking down now to the
end of this ceasefire the turks saying
they could resume their offensive what's
happening on the ground there well
certainly yeah the ceasefire seems to be
holding but there are serious concerns
because certainly according to our
sources these are fighters with the Free
Syrian Army that have been very much
part of this Turkish military campaign
in northern Syria they're saying that
there are still huge areas that the SDF
those Kurdish forces still control so it
seems at this stage doubtful whether
those forces will have withdrawn in time
before this deadline this deadline hits
which is well around about six hours
from now we've been speaking to to some
of the people who've been working some
of the military that have been working
inside Rassilon which is behind me some
of those Syrian Arab fighters they're
saying that there have been a deployment
there has been deployment of more true
small fighters both to the east and to
the west suggesting that the Turks could
well be readying themselves for a new
front if indeed the demands that are
being made by turkey in this us brokered
ceasefire deal are not met